لا لدخول المتنزهات والحدائق ثم لا لقاعات
الرياضه لا للحمامات العامه ولا للملاهي
والان لا للدراسه لا ات تحولت لحبال تخنق
نساء افغانستان ليصبحن عاجزات عن ابسط
الانشطه اليوميه التسريبات الاخيره من
داخل طالبان تعطي اشاره بنيه الحركه حرمان
النساء من التعليم
طالبان هبه الله اخوان زاد يتجه لاغلاق
الجامعات بحجه تنظيم تعليم الفتيات
والرجوع الى علماء الدين
مصادر خاصه من وزاره الخارجيه في
افغانستان اكدت للعربيه ان اخوان زادت عمد
تعيين ندى محمد نديم وزيرا للتعليم العالي
لكونه من اكثر علماء طالبان تطرفا والذي
ادلى بتصريحات غاضبه حول اوضاع مخزيه في
الجامعات
المصادر ذاتها ذكرت للعربيه ان القرار
اثار خلافا بين جناحي طالبان بعض اع حكومه
متخوفون من رد فعل المجتمع الدولي وما قد
يحمله القرار من عقوبات وعزله ابرزهم وزير
الداخليه سراج الدين حقاني ووزير الدفاع
الملا يعقوب
قرار وقف التعليم تجرات عليه طالبا بعد
اقل من اسبوع من تصريحات الامم المتحده
والتي وصفت معامله طالبان للنساء بجرائم
ضد الانسانيه وانها الاسوا على مستوى
العالم
وعود وتطمينات قدمتها حركه طالبه بعد ان
عادت الى سده الحكم العام الماضي لتلمع
صورتها امام المجتمع الدولي وتحضى
بالشرعيه الدوليه بعد ان كان وضع المراه
في افغانستان اكبر مخاوف في العالم لتعد
الحركه بحفظ حقوق النساء من تعليم وعمل
وانشطه حياتيه لتتراجع عنها بعد سنه من
الحكم